one thing I wanted to ask actually is
like are you planning to like kind of
extend to other games as well with power
yeah definitely definitely I think
that's in the books for yeah 2023 this
year
um it's it's and that's like kind of
part of it is like surveying which game
to go next uh would you be interested in
like because you know you you obviously
like massive Pokemon fan right like have
you ever thought about like going into
like the competitive Pokemon scene or
that's interesting that started really
hitting my like for you page on YouTube
yeah what's that guy really blowing up
recently is it Wolfie yeah Wolfie yeah
you're making some great content yeah
like really good storytelling he's been
uh innovating but also when you when
you're playing with a Nintendo property
so yeah the answer is no yeah yeah
to get something Nintendo will actively
be like [__] this [__] you don't play
our games longer than we tell you I just
don't think they're really like
understand the scene enough and they I I
feel like it's gone way too long we
can't use that as an excuse I think they
understand it they just don't want it
yeah I feel like that is not their goals
they they are that [__] Granddad
who's just like what is Esports I don't
understand this apparently watch Real
Sports that's not real Sports yeah
because it like it feels like you know
especially in Japan I don't know how big
the Esports scene is in Japan uh but I
know it's like almost non-existent in
terms of like league is it is it
valorant or is it valent's pretty big
Apex won the Battle Royale war in Japan
oh yeah which is even close yeah and
like they're getting Aaron Jaegers and
they're still not winning
how do you got posters everywhere enough
they're trying to win a war over there I
think it's like kids kids love fortnite
in Japan yeah yeah but like the moment
they kind of get older yeah it's Apex
everyone plays yeah but but Valentine is
also massively taken off yeah uh yeah
YouTubers for that yeah a lot of
YouTubers actually yeah there's push
Apex
um yeah right I think it was actually
the V tubers that originally especially
with Apex blew it up in Japan because
like there was like a bunch of like
pretty top level Japanese YouTubers who
got really [__] good at Apex well
they also have like uh I think it's not
maybe bi-weekly or monthly uh YouTuber
Apex tournaments oh yeah yeah pretty big
yeah basically Vichy was uh control the
Japanese meters all games gets played
right mobas they do not like in Japan no
yeah okay that's Korea yeah Korea yeah
yeah yeah does not want mobiles are you
playing any games outside of uh
like fortnite and uh yeah what games are
you doing personally you know what's
crazy it's gonna sound Koreans but it's
actually fortnite
it's okay I I played TFT and that's like
the most cringe game of all oh actually
you know what I've started playing a bit
uh Super Auto pets actually casually
that is kind of like TFT yeah it is
that one's yeah surprisingly fun to play
uh yeah with friends as well we used to
play the DOTA one the DOTA chess and
then I just that was the first Auto Show
yeah that was yeah yeah and then like
yoink and then yeah it's always funny
how those happened
um but yeah no honestly it's like I'll
probably wake up and still like get in
at least a game of fortnite right I'm
probably addicted to fortnite right like
and I don't even make much content on
anymore it's just like some habitually
ingrained in me for five years of making
content on the game because a lot of
times in that journey of like making
content when I was daily uploading and
stuff it would be let's just play to
figure out what to record and like what
can I like let's let's on the Fly here
make something while playing a game yeah
and then that just become a habit to
just play a game every day and it's like
well I I think the big thing about
getting into a new competitive game is
that when you put so much time into like
learning the mechanics of one game it's
really hard to just jump into to like
jump into another game casually and be
like I want to spend time learning this
game now right because that's why I will
never play another MOBA outside of
League because like I there was a time
when I enjoyed League of Legends I spent
God knows how many hours just learning
the basic [__] how like just how to
play the game and yeah how the game
works and I do not have that time in my
life anymore yeah you know sure sure
yeah is there any like if you could pick
any games that you would want power to
like kind of like be represented in like
yeah regardless of like artistics yeah
regardless of logistics I mean we wanted
to do we wanted to do valorant we were
looking at that pretty heavily then they
went franchised right which yeah what
does that mean when they get franchised
uh essentially it was like kind of like
invite only and we weren't in it yet so
it kind of made sense like but they
didn't pick any Australian teams in the
franchise model there's no yeah there
was gonna be one and then they went
bankrupt
um
everybody's going Bang
we'll see LG recently announced yeah
darling back and then God fired all of
their employees yeah and then I think V1
was talking about looking for a merger I
think I saw her like
saw TSM down back or something like that
would you like if TSM is dialing back
that's pretty scary for the whole
industry because that's like one of the
biggest brand name orgs yeah yeah
exactly
um so I'm guessing I'm guessing being an
Australian Esports team you guys are
always seen as The Underdogs yeah and
actually I love it because when we win
it's gonna feel so [__] good like and
that's why you gotta get behind us
to win right like and that's not that's
like Aussie Spirits Underdog like yeah
that is it how much do you think crappy
Australian internet has played a role in
their weekends yeah because I was gonna
ask it's definitely part of it like
we'll still get Rocket League games and
it's like guys drop down it's like oh
yeah internet like yeah like there's
like a little like I think we have a
higher
I could be wrong but I think there's
like a we take more referee pauses like
in any other region in rlcs because it's
like yeah internet like it's just a
common thing especially when people
playing out rural it's like yeah okay
he's gonna say out like will he come
back uh coin flip we don't know yeah
yeah
um definitely definitely a pot and I
would say even YouTube as well like
early on I had to get my video done by 8
PM so that I could upload it overnight
yeah I was there as well yeah yeah I I I
because when I was living in Australia
making content I was also uploading
daily yeah and uh there'd be like an off
peak and then there'll be an on-peak and
if you didn't upload during the uh or if
you uploaded during the on Peak then by
the end of the month your internet was
just [__] yeah because there's always
a cap to it so you had what yeah so how
it works yeah oh we were broken for sure
yeah so basically is notoriously bad
yeah so basically how it worked was that
I think it's like between like uh 12 a.m
and when was it it was like for me I
think I started at 10 p.m yeah it was
like it was basically it was like 10 10
P.M M ish that would be an off peak
which is basically it's basically like
you're separating the data cap into two
halves one during the day and one during
the night and if you exhausted it during
one of the Peaks then the other Peak
would be affected yes but your internet
would just go down to dial-up speed
until it would refresh the next month
and so when I was uploading so I went so
when I was uploading daily I had to
basically upload it overnight because
not only was the internet so incredibly
[__] so that it took all night time
yeah yeah but also if I did it during
the day then I would exhaust the peak
and then my dad would come into my room
pissed off as [__] me like why is my
internet at dial up speed because you
uploaded all this [__] and basically
capped out our data yeah and you lived
in Sydney so you weren't like in the
middle of [__] nowhere dude I had
point three uploads were you in the city
uh I was just outside of the city I was
in Northern Beach because apparently for
like the the way they like refresh the
internet is for some places they started
outside then in the city like they
didn't start from the the city and then
go out they went out from the suburbs
into the city I think Melbourne's like
that from whatever right where like
people in Melbourne still in the city
kind of have [__] in that uh yeah no I
don't I don't think it was like that for
us I think it was just kind of in Sydney
it was just like a like overnight
everyone would just like get a refreshed
yeah uh but either way like I had to
basically like really down scale my
videos to make the files as small as
possible one because it would take a
billion years to upload so that I
wouldn't be able to make the daily
upload schedule but two if I was
uploading like a gigabyte video files
every single day dude my internet would
be out in like the first 10 days yeah
and then I'd have dial up for the next
20 days which is just like when I first
got an edited horrendous I started
uploading the raw footage and that's
when I realized oh [__] my internet is
so slow yeah it's a YouTube video you
know you you'd render it and it would
come out yeah and it's 1080P and it made
me come out to like 700 megabytes yeah
gigabyte tops right right but then when
you start learning raw footage and then
you know this raw footage is three hours
long and there's two camera angles like
oh this is gonna take four days yeah so
I couldn't upload 1080p videos while I
was living in Australia because the
files were too big yeah so the first two
and a half years I was uploading 720p at
most and I was using like a program to
like basically scale it down yeah it's a
sacrifice like graphical quality or like
audio quality just so I could upload it
without going over my account crazy yeah
and that was fun and then you know by
the time I moved out to Australia
because my PC was basically on 24 hours
for two and a half years straight uh it
exploded one day and it like actually
burst into flames and I was like well
guess I'm moving to Japan now wow that's
the catalog you take it for granted in
Japan though how how lucky you are to
have oh yeah yeah high speeds everywhere
because you're you haven't seen speeds
even through like mobile connections
yeah and there's no cap either yeah
there's no cap yeah yeah I upload like a
terabyte of files I'm like all right
I'll be dumb by dinner time yeah
that's crazy is uh is the Australian
isn't that still bad it's not bad now
like I've you there's like a couple good
providers now and like they've got NBN
infrastructure in most places the
national Broadband Network yeah yeah
which was yeah Harry for a while there
but it's good now it's yeah not all
terabytes but like you know we do a
couple gigabytes nice yes hell yeah
how's the Ping in Australian like
competitive games because it's it's like
a meme in the league Community where
everyone's trying to figure out why n a
like North America sucks so bad and
there's like a million different like
[__] excuses one of them is just like
oh it's because of the pigs like because
the servers are like in the middle of
America yeah the servers are in the
middle of America and they're all like
all in California L.A so it's like yeah
the pro players can't get like good
practice so what happened like 60 ping
right 60 Ms that's kind of have a lot
yeah that's I think a lot of people do
play on like 60. yeah yeah I think in
Korea it's like three or something right
it's like it's like 10 or below 10 in
Korea yeah yeah I think I get like 15 in
Tokyo dude when I was in Australia and
like before the national Broadband
Network came out and I was playing like
Gmod with like a bunch of my friends in
America like I had like 300 on a good
day yeah yeah well that was like yeah
because during my early days doing
Minecraft like 2014 like I was recording
with
Americans yeah I was the only Aussie and
I was like it was the meme of like me
being like flying around yeah
this like yeah they call me like the
blur because I would be blurring just
talking through everything but yeah I
mean it was good fun waking up at bad
hours
um it's good it was grind days for sure
yeah but like how bad is like the Ping
now when it comes oh yeah facing kind of
like a competitive scene here in
Australia yes that's not bad so all the
servers based in Sydney
um right yeah so we might like we did
that one thing where we flew our players
down to Sydney and played some games out
there to have zero pain because in
fortnite ping is essential for taking
their walls so you pickaxe the wall and
it would be like who places it first
next and it's who's ever closest to the
server right yeah they said they added
spamming it right yeah you're both
spamming it and it's like they say it's
a coin flip on like a 50 50 chance but
if your ping is good enough it doesn't
do the coin slip and you just get it
yeah right um and like that's a big key
mechanical like fighting because if you
take their wall you can edit and then
get a free shot yeah right so that's
like if you build the wall in fortnite
you can actually like this because it's
a three by three you can actually like
press a button that allows you to remove
parts of the wall yeah so you can
imagine it right if you have a if you've
boxed someone in and you're the one who
built the wall you can quickly you know
exactly when you're going to remove a
section of this wall then you can just
shoot through it ah so like I could just
remove a portion to shoot them and put
it back oh wow yeah yeah so that's I
can't do anything oh yeah they just sit
there and take it yeah um so that's why
yeah so I guess ping is a big factor I
didn't know that was a big deal yeah so
that's like uh like in America right now
they even just did it with um fortnite
where they had the e-servers and the
West servers and they just randomly like
hey it's all going Central so like all
these guys have set up boot camps on
East Coast because that was the biggest
dominant competitive scene and I've all
just moved to Texas
Jesus Christ it's crazy to think that
like so much infrastructure that's
already built could just be overturned
by where they're like yeah I'm gonna
move the server yeah yeah it's kind of
insane to think no it's wild it's wild
yeah I mean like I I don't know how
big kind of like Esports plays a factor
into business decisions that they make
yeah I can't imagine it plays like the
biggest Factor you know for America I
think yeah it definitely would be like
we think about it for religious it's
kind of like um the Apex teams in
Australia are actually I know I said
before that you know Australian teams go
International they don't win the Apex
teams and I actually got to meet uh Jen
Burch and uh Jen Burton I think his name
is
um in a tournament I did last week so
he's actually a part of the elusive
Australians that go overseas and win
right they won a couple of the
international Apex tournaments uh last
year and so they will qualify through
Asia play against Japanese teams yeah
and actually win on like 160 ping like
games wow because the game's got good
enough net code that like and I
experience it's really not hard to play
on bad ping yeah it's actually very good
for it like I played the whole
tournament 200 ping and it felt fine
it's like OverWatch is like that
OverWatch when I played it I noticed
that the Ping didn't feel that bad like
other games like uh Valerian you're like
I'm I die now yeah I thought that's
horrible for high ping as well yeah
right right but yeah no so like they'll
play on 160 and win which I think is
that's pretty cool